wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
eine bitte ich weiß gewissen und du hast
jedes recht dazu
ich habe gelogen ich bin nicht sagt ich
habe keine restaurants und und ich komme
auch nicht aus frankreich jüngst immer
ums geld
das geld zum kaufen des champagners das
geld zum bezahlen des urlaubs ist alles
wieder ich will nicht zurück st kannst
du das nicht verstehen
mir ist das geld egal ich brauche das
zum glücklichsein nicht bei irgendetwas
war
manche ich meine war irgendetwas war von
dem was du gesagt hast und bitte bitte
dieses eine mal glück mich nicht
[Musik]
alles über mich ist gelogen aber aber
jetzt seit unserem urlaub ist plötzlich
alles wahr geworden ich will einen
neuanfang mit dir und ich glaube das
alles funktionieren kann ich weiß du
musst ein furchtbares gefühlschaos haben
und ich weiß dass ich schuld bin
aber mein herz und mein verstand sagen
mir fang bloß nicht an von herzen
verstand zu sprechen beides hast du
nicht und ich glaube dir kein einziges
ja ich will dich nie mehr wiedersehen
[Musik]